you know was pretty much Amazon I'm
breaded I'm at a room and I'm Nick and
we're about to do some first times at
BuzzFeed first time you got recognized
at public I think I the one of the first
ones I can remember was actually being
in target yeah I was in target I was
just grabbing stuff for the house
actually and I was so thrown off because
I like somebody called my name but like
I thought it was like one in like
somebody like a friend I knew and then
when they ask for a patient was like oh
oh this is I was like oh this is oh I
forgot yeah
so I'm supposed to take picture with you
now yeah it was probably was probably
really awkward say the first thing I
like to do when I wake up in the morning
is probably like walk outside I take my
dog out I have a little dog named Percy
he's a staffordshire bull terrier mix of
the lab so just be my mornings with him
first CD you ever bought I'm not gonna
say I bought it but with the first CD I
got into his bass you boys but yo I'm
not gonna lie to there was just one CD
than my sister had Britney Spears and I
forget which album it was but the colors
on it were mad quite remember seeing it
me like those colors and dope first time
meeting a celebrity well there's two
times I could think of there's one time
we met Liam Liam yeah Liam from one
direction
yeah like Lily first day we got in LA
pretty wild
I think the craziest time though was
when we went to haul Z's party like
after iHeartRadio awards it was just
awesome there were so many people there
and we were just like am Katy Perry's
ran from my face my Cyrus is dancing to
my right partynextdoor is yeah it was
just it was just crazy it was like a big
culture shock for me shower shower yeah
we need some fresh towels fresh clothes
first band mint you go to for advice
actually honestly probably probably
Edwin cuz we share room because he's
just like right there
I just click I don't want to get up and
go somewhere else it's too much work if
I got something wrong I don't talk about
it I'll write about it
okay first celebrity crush I don't know
if this counts but I like had probably
the biggest crush on the pink Power
Ranger I was a kid I loved the power
dude that's my girl first concert I ever
attended 21 pilots at first will appear
in Pennsylvania their fire they they
crowd surf with drums and it's pretty
fire first time messing up on stage ever
yeah our first ever performance as a
group like publicly you know first time
ha something was going on with my in-ear
and I missed the cue forgot the beat
drop so it was like so I'll be waiting
by my phone was this one I applied for
McDonald's but they picked me up quicker
than McDonald's didn't lucky this one
I'm just gonna I'm a magician I'm gonna
read its mind no just kidding already
ready but I said uh first red carpet
experience was definitely it was Teen
Choice teen it was blue so I guess my
first red carpet experience was uh
whatever we did after that VMAs nothing
I don't think the first red carpet was
like it was like our third carpet it was
finally read good my first pet I just
talked about him like my first cellphone
pet is my dog crazy my first pet was a
snake it's pretty cool man
I got him tattooed on my body he's right
here first cell phone boy if you don't
if you don't my first cell phone was a
sidekick Tony Hawk edition limited
edition my first phone was literally a
Motorola flip phone but the first one it
was literally like this small flip phone
little antenna comes out the side like
yeah like it was it was real my first
phone wasn't even my like my first but
it was like me my sister shared it it
was like it was a green little phone
with two little antennas it looked like
a little alien and it had four and four
numbers had one two three four and then
nine-one-one and it was five four
numbers my mom my dad my grandma my
grandpa but I never had a razor it was
very salty very salty about it well uh
this is all fun and all but uh we gots
to go
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more videos and subscribe like
comment you know fomo tour this summer a
lot of things bra love you
[Music]